un bonsoir à tous bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
tout de suite voici les grands titres de
l'actualité de ce lundi 31 mai emmanuel
macron et angela merkel appelle les
états unis et le danemark à s'expliquer
sur les allégations d'espionnage de
certains responsables dans la
chancelière allemande selon des médias
danoise et européen les états unis ont
été pillés des responsables politiques
en europe entre 2012 et 2014 de surprend
avec l'aide des services de
renseignements danois
la chancelière allemande qui présidait
aujourd'hui pour la dernière fois avec
emmanuel macron le conseil des ministres
franco-allemand gala merkel quittera son
poste en septembre après des élections
législatives au bout de 16 ans au
pouvoir est les trois candidats à la
chancellerie sont des pros zoko européen
convaincu et juge le franco-allemand
fondamentale fait valoir l'ambassadeur
allemand le vieux continent toujours et
sa relation avec la russie
une conférence se tenait aujourd'hui
organisée par le conseil russe pour les
affaires internationales l'ambassade du
portugal et la délégation de l'ue à
moscou le chef de la diplomatie russe
qui se dit prêt à reprendre les
relations normales avec l'europe met sur
un pied d'égalité
encore beaucoup d'obstacles avant la
formation d'un gouvernement selon le
chef de l'opposition en israël les
tractations se poursuivent
anciens alliés de benjamin netanyahu
naftali bennet chef de file de la droite
radicale négocié son ralliement à yaïr
lapid elle le centriste en passe de
former avec plusieurs autres partis un
gouvernement du changement selon la
rhétorique qui pourrait faire tomber
benyamin netanyahou au pouvoir depuis 15
ans
[Musique]
les etats unis ont donc espionner des
responsables politiques en europe dont
la chancelière allemande angela merkel
de 2012 à 2014 et ce avec l'aide des
services de renseignements danois
révélation hier des médias danois et
européen le président écran et un gala
merkel réunis en conseil des ministres
franco-allemand de manche ce soir des
réponses à leurs deux alliés écouter ce
n'est pas acceptable entre ali de
manière très claire
ça l'est encore moins entre alliés et
partenaires européens et il n'y a pas de
classe entre nous pour le soupçon c'est
pourquoi ce que nous attendons c'est la
clarté complète
nous avons demandé à ce que nos
partenaires danoise américain apporte
toutes les informations sur ces
révélations et sur ces faits passés et
donc nous sommes en attente de ses
réponses
ce sont les personnes qualifiées qui
auront ces échanges
d'une part pour apporter toute la clarté
sur ces faits passés et surtout apporter
toute la clarté sur les pratiques
présente j'ai été rassuré par le fait
que le danemark a dit très clairement ce
qu'il pense de cette affaire et jusqu'à
présent je vois une bonne base en plus
de la clarification des faits or pour
arriver à une relation de confiance
souffre à trop en dessous de ce qu'on
essaie donc un bis repetita pour l'
agence de renseignement américain la n
essaye déjà accusé en 2013 d'espionner
angela merkel épinglé pour avoir opéré
depuis berlin l'agencé cette fois blâmer
pour mener des écoutes depuis le
danemark avec l'accord des services
secrets du pays
les explications de katia technique les
états unis épaulé par le danemark pour
espionner des figures politiques
européennes
la haine est ce l agence de
renseignements américains auraient pour
cela utiliser des systèmes d'écouté
câbles sous marins de télécommunications
des danois avec leur accord les faits se
sont déroulés entre 2012 et 2014 où
barack obama qu'ils ont été révélés par
une enquête conjointe de la télévision
publique danoise dr
et de plusieurs médias internationaux
dont le quotidien français le monde
les journalistes danois ont évoqué un
rapport interne des services de
renseignement du pays
opération dunham les américains avaient
accès au fameux câble sous marin en
vertu d'un partenariat passé avec les
services de renseignement militaires
danois f
ce qui était visé par ces écoutes en
premier lieu la chancelière allemande
angela merkel
pour elle il s'agit de la saison 2
puisque un premier scandale d'espionnage
la concernant avait éclaté en 2013
autres personnalités ciblées en
allemagne le ministre allemand des
affaires étrangères qui officie à
l'époque frank walter steinmeier ainsi
que le chef de l'opposition peer
steinbrück qui a vivement réagi il est
grotesque que des services de
renseignements amy intercepte et
espionne effectivement les principaux
représentants d'autres pays
politiquement je considère que c'est un
scandale d'autres responsables
politiques ont été écoutés à leur insu
en suède en norvège et en france sans
que les noms on est pour le moment était
dévoilée et pour remplir leur fiche
les américains avaient accès aux textos
aux appels ainsi qu'à toutes leurs
activités sur internet y compris les
messageries les recherches
la ministre danoise de la défense trine
bramsen à son poste depuis juin 2019
n'aurait eu connaissance de ces faits
que depuis moins d'un an
elle a estimé que l'espionnage
systématique par des alliés est
inacceptable
cet incident permet de comprendre la
mesure de l'espionnage à grande échelle
opéré par la haine et c'est durant l'ère
obama
les médias ont déjà révélé en novembre
2020 que la collaboration secrète dano
américaines avaient visé des activités
industrielles et qu'ils ont même
poursuivi malgré les révélations de la
sphère snowden en 2013 et angela merkel
avait déjà fait les frais de
l'espionnage américain avertit d'
écoutes menées par la haine essaimé
depuis berlin
elle avait demandé des comptes à barack
obama il avait botté en touche et fait
savoir qu'il n'y aurait pas d' écoute de
la chancelière à l'avenir selon le
quotidien allemand bild am sonntag le
président américain était au courant dès
2010 de telles opérations secrètes
n'oublions pas en france de scandale
lorsque laurent fabius avait demandé que
la station des coûts de la nes
posé sur le toit de l'ambassade
américaine à paris soit retirée le
lanceur d'alerté douar snowden était le
premier à dénoncer un réseau de
surveillance mondiale généralisée par la
haine et c il a réagi à ce nouveau
scandale
ironie de l'histoire il faudra désormais
demander des comptes à l'homme de la
situation qui a été le vice-président de
barack obama surveille d'al baida n'est
bien préparé pour répondre à cela lors
de sa prochaine visite en europe
car bien sûr il a été profondément
impliqué dans ce scandale la première
fois une divulgation publique totale
devrait être exigé non seulement de la
part du danemark mais également de son
partenaire principal et quid du faut
allier le danemark le gouvernement
danois a déjà limogé le chef du
renseignement militaire en août 2020
ainsi que de hauts responsables pour une
autre affaire l'europe semble condamnée
à laver son linge sale en famille et
blanchir ses membres petit espionnage
entre amis dont que cherchent les
américains en écoutant leurs alliés de
leur côté des européens ont-ils les
moyens de se défendre c'est l'objet de
notre décryptage ce soir
[Musique]
pour en parler nous sommes avec eux
pierre martinet un ancien agent du
service action de la dgse bonsoir pierre
martinet merci d'être avec nous à vos
côtés françois chauvancy général de
brigade expert en géostratégie bonsoir
général souvent si merci d'être avec
nous à tous les deux donc une première
affaire en révéler en 2013 le pendant de
cette affaire à plusieurs personnalités
politiques européennes de premier plan
écouter très attentivement manifestement
entre 2012 et 2014 par l' agence de
renseignement américaine
françois choffat aussi question naïve et
bête mais enfin c'est normal d'espionner
ses amis je pense qu'il y à deux
dimensions la première année politique
comment accepter qu'un allié écoute son
allié par des voies d'espionnage la
deuxième est pragmatique
comment se faire effacer finalement
l'illusion que on aimerait bien savoir
ce que portent nos alliés il n'y a rien
que de plus naturel de entre guillemets
pragmatiquement et non pas politiquement
de chercher à savoir ce que pensent ses
alliés maintenant tout le reportage
connaît de montrer montre bien d'abord
que curieusement saint commander une
administration démocrate qui a voulu
espionner quand même ses alliés
quand on voit le débat aux états unis
sur les démocrates et les républicains
on peut quand même s'interroger
et puis dernier point quand même c'est
que quand même
ne faisons pas d'illusions savoir ce que
pense l'autre qui soit un adversaire un
ennemi ou un allié c'est une partie du
renseignement maintenant le mot
confiance est à moins important je crois
que vous l'avez souligné votre porte
avec angela merkel
on doit avoir confiance dans ses alliés
et si ses alliés vous espionne
comment peut-on avoir confiance en dieu
pierre martin et là on apprend quand
même par rapport à 2013 et les premières
révélations on apprend quand même que là
il s'agit d'une espionnage de grande
ampleur avec des câbles télécom alors je
suis pas spécialiste en la matière vous
allez mieux
nous l'expliqué et avec une complicité
d'un ami européen a priori le danemark
un rasta et amir évidemment la preuve
que le gouvernement le savait mais quand
même ça fait la différence non alors la
nsa et ait été créé pour respirer
espionner le reste le reste du monde
donc pour moi du tout étonné que qu'on
découvre à nouveau que j'avais laissé
espionne en europe vous et fermez vos
amis vous en général on se concentre sur
les héros et non là alors il faut il
faut utiliser ben alors il ya espionner
et avoir avoir un peu de l'information
c'est pour moi c'est deux choses
différentes parce que dans six si on
emploie le terme espionnage a une
connotation un peu plus guerrière que
quelques que avoir du renseignement il y
avait relevé une phrase d'un des
conseillers à la sécurité nationale du
jimmy carter qui disait sur le ton de
l'humour bien évidemment il faut bien
qu'on écoute nos amis nos alliés pour
vérifier qu'ils sont toujours nos amis
donc il y a deux aspects dans cette dans
cette affaire enfin je veux dire pour
moi honnêtement pour moi ce n'est pas
une affaire c'est un non événement il y
à la guerre économique qui est une vraie
guerre économique qui fait plus de morts
que les guerres conventionnelles tout le
monde est en haut de cette pyramide il
ya les états unis il ya la chine lui
prouve que les chinoises font la même
chose que les américains et il est très
important pour les américains d'avoir de
l'information en europe parce que les
chinois où l'europe est aussi à le
on va dire le terrain guerre économique
des chinois donc je pense que c'est en
moi c'est un billard à trois bandes de
la part des états unis
mais dans le monde du renseignement il
ya une phrase que mon emploi du temps
c'est la nécessité de savoir la
nécessité de connaître c'est très
important de savoir ce que pensent nos
amis encore peut-être plus que pensent
nos ennemis alors selon moi enfin ça
c'est peut-être par naïveté ce soir je
dirais que avec nos amis ça n'irait pas
plus loin qu'une avoir de l'information
sans forcément l'utiliser ou l'utiliser
de façon économique parce que encore une
fois la guerre économique fait rage dans
le monde et ça va encore ça va encore
être plus le cas après après le
phénomène qu vide
donc pour répondre concrètement à votre
question il n'y a rien d'étonnant il ya
certains français qui s'en étonne mais
la russie là la chine israël le font
également
alors il ya une alliance à waimes et
pardonnez-moi pierre martinet mai mais
là je vais réagir faire agir aussi et
françois chaumont cinéma enfin quand
c'est la russie on est bien placé sur
cette scène pour le savoir c'est l'écrit
dans fait c'est un coup de sanctions
enfin bref voilà c'était les grands mais
lyon a tancé les états unis bon voilà on
sait pas bien espionné non mais là
franchement je suis un peu partout dans
que pour une fois on enfin c'est
tellement flagrant mais je suis d'accord
avec vous je suis d'accord avec vous
mais je partage votre opinion c'est
absolument fin pour moi c'est la même
chose
je suis d'accord avec vous il n'ya que
encore une fois je je j'abonde dans
votre sens il n'y a qu'en europe qu'on
s'étonne que les américains espionnent
alors franchement ça va pas aller bien
loin il va y avoir peut-être une
convocation d'un ambassadeur et encore 2
deux numéros 3 d'une ambassade et ça
s'arrêtera là parce que c'est pas la
première fois que ça arrive je me
souviens avoir fait un article là dessus
il ya quelques années au moment de la
chute du premier espionnage de
l'allemagne voilà ça n'a rien donné
ça ne donnera rien et il est important
que condé des informations encore une
fois l'information d'avoir de
l'information c'est bien mais savoir ce
qu'on en fait c'est c'est une chose
différente 1,6 et de la formation pour
faire de l'offensif sur nos amis ok mais
si c'est de la formation pour avoir
comme on dirait quand vous avez la
formation c'est comme aux échecs c'est
un coup d'avancé je suis désolé de
l'emmener dans le monde économique dans
le monde de l'entreprise
alors on sait pas si c'est du cinéma où
l'on met enfin emmanuel macron avait pas
l'air de prendre
voilà aussi bien que vous le décrivez
avec hargne et la merkel on les a
entendu tout à l'heure dans la lignée
quelques heures plus tôt je vous propose
d'écouter le secrétaire d'état chargé
aux affaires clément bonne entre alliés
il doit y avoir une confiance une
coopération minimale donc ses effets
potentiels sont graves
il faut les vérifier et ensuite en tirer
les conséquences en termes de
coopération
françois changement si claire martin et
voilà un relativisme enfin quand même
ils ont pas l'air de tellement bien le
coin on et on peut les comprendre il
faudra en tirer les conséquences
à quoi doit-on s'attendre si ces faits
sont établis
oui enfin je pense que je rejoins une
partie de l'argumentation qui a été
avancé par un martinez je dis simplement
que martinez pardon dit simplement que
ce que j'ai dit tout à l'heure il ya une
relation politique et il ya une relation
pragmatique je dit pas autre chose
politique comment voulez-vous nous
gouvernement ne dise pas le ne condamne
pas cette situation
ancien ne leur aplomb pas sous un
gouvernement démocrate aux états unis
donc on ne peut pas ne pas réagir et ne
pas dire ce n'est pas bien
maintenant il ya une réalité qu'elle
soit économique dont je ne partage pas
dit comment le point de vue économique
mais il est aussi politique il est aussi
relations internationales en général ce
sont des rapports de force
doit savoir ce que les autres pensent et
c'est vrai que nos alliés n'ont pas
toujours prouvé dans le passé qu'ils
étaient forcément des alliés vous avez
aussi leur propre agenda
comme tout état il ya des agendas
nationaux maintenant je rebondirai ce
que vous avez dit à quelques instants
sur effectivement fièrement cette
disproportion entre accusé la russie
d'un côté et ne pas accuser des états
unis oui les etats unis doivent montrer
qu' on peut leur faire confiance et que
l'attitude qu'ils ont eues il y a
quelques années doit bien être pro on
doit bien prouvé aujourd'hui que ce n'a
plus lieu
quand on relit les articles concernant
l'administration obama et ils vont très
bien on va arrêter on va se calmer
bon fou rire effet que c'est vrai
effectivement avec l'administration joe
biden aujourd'hui qui a été quand même
parfaitement au contact d'obama c'est la
moindre des choses
il pourrait au moins confirmé qu'il n'ya
plus d'actes je dirais je reprends un
mot espionnage tellement plus simple
pour le commun des mortels vis-à-vis de
ses alliés je pense que l'administration
bayonne doit tout à fait confirmé que la
et nsa n'écoute plus ses alliés
car ce que vous avez évoqué il ya
quelques instants encore sur le mot
confiance on ne peut pas développer la
notion de confiance entre alliés si des
alliés espionne les autres donc en
l'occurrence il ya un soupçon
d'espionnage
il est normal que les politiques
français allemands et autres disent ça
ne peut pas continuer et il est temps
que joe byden dans ce cas là disent bien
oui non et nsa n'espionne plus des
dirigeants européens et alliés depuis 4
5 ans voilà nous sommes dans la
politique nous sommes pas dans la
pratique du renseignement donc je
comprends tout à fait dans la pratique
du renseignement peut-être qu'il y aura
des
des entorses maintenant il ya un point
qui n'a pas été relevé le point qui n'a
pas été relevé je suis très surpris
d'entendre dire que le services secrets
danois ont participé à cette action
allait refuser
évidemment parce que c'est ce qui retire
la tension dans cette affaire est ce qui
n'avait pas été relevé en 2013 alors on
sait pas si le gouvernement est au
courant c'est pas et habib enfin en tout
cas que les services secrets danois et
aider ça ça semble à peu près en tout
cas c'était des révélations de ce
week-end c'est très étonnant n'est ce
pas je devrais dire bien plus c'est
inadmissible il ya un devoir de loyauté
envers son gouvernement envers ces
politiques est un service de
renseignement qui travailleraient entre
guillemets dans le domaine de
l'espionnage au profit d'une nation
étrangère
moi ça m'interpelle j'appelle presque ça
de la trahison pour pas utiliser un
terme trop fort mais quand même c'est
une forme de trahison
sauf s'il ya eu un aval politique
donc je pense qu'il va y avoir entre
guillemets des règlements de comptes au
danemark sur ce qui aurait pu autoriser
des actions que moi je considère comme
inacceptable mais pardonnez moi mais
quel intérêt pour le danemark d'aidé
comme ça les états unis à faire
espionner
les a niées je pense que c'est pas
forcément l'objectif d'en de d'espionner
les alliés simplement il ya eu une
convergence d'intérêts un moment donné
entre les services secrets danois est là
est né c'est pour dire bah tiens après
tout pourquoi pas on se connaît on se
fait confiance il n'y a pas de
répercussions sur l'avenir et l'union
européenne
bon je dirais qu'à la limite on pourrait
comprendre que pas alors je l'utilisé à
un thème qui n'est peut-être pas adapté
le mot copinage les personnes du
renseignement se connaissent ils se
fréquentent
ils se rencontrent et je crois peut-être
qu'à eues à un échange de service mais
je ne suis pas un expert du domaine qui
simplement c'est comme ça que je
comprendrais les choses et je pense
qu'il ya eu un excès de deux confiante
la part des danois vis-à-vis de l'année
c'est qu'il faudra bien expliquer
pourquoi il ya eu cette collusion
là par contre le terme est fort c'est
une collusion entre les services secrets
danois d'un état souverain avec les
états unis
sans forcément l'accord du pouvoir
politique et là je crois que c'est un
vrai problème qui devra être éclairci
pierre martinet sur cette implication
danoise alors je partage évidemment ce
qui vient d'être dit bhl parce que il
faut savoir alors est ce que est ce que
les câbles ont été mis à disposition
sans savoir ce qui à quoi il allait
servir réellement ou est ce que comme
dit le général
il y avait vraiment un copinage la tête
des services de renseignements danois et
américains pour mettre en place une
vraie machine d'espionnage qui partirait
de là ils sont répartis de la du
danemark
si si les services de renseignement
danois ont agi seuls dans leur coin sans
avoir l'autorisation
l'ordre du politique parce que je
rappelle quand même que plus minuteur
les services de renseignement ce que c
est ce que c'est seulement possible de
se passer de l'autorisation du
gouvernement dans ces cas la théorie non
en théorie non moi depuis enfin j'ai
souvent eu cette question de la part des
journalistes
est-ce que vous avez vous avez pris des
initiatives pour faire at elle pour
espionner talent et être personne ben
non on est aux ordres des politiques je
rappelle que les services de les
services sont aux ordres des politiques
et policiers les militaires
on est tous au service des politiques
donc s'il ya eu s'il y avait eu un
individu seul dans son coin et qui a
pris l'initiative de collaborer avec les
services secrets avec les services
américains
effectivement c'est la cena trahison
c'est de la trahison puisqu'il va il a
outrepassé son rôle au quotidien
en revanche s'il ya eu un accord tacite
avec entre les deux états pour qu'il y
ait juste utilisation de ces fameux
câble sans savoir jusqu jusqu'où ça
allait aller
est ce que les américains n'auraient pas
en fumée entre guillemets le les les
bâlois s'est aussi possible je ne sais
pas j'ai pas le fin mot de l'histoire
je n'ai pas accès a évidemment l'anc est
donc il ya deux possibilités soit ils
ont c'est une initiative de la part des
droits et ça c'est gravissime et c'est
condamnable soit il y a une vraie
relation mais sans savoir jusqu'où ça
pouvait aller là aussi ils sont assez
légers dans leur relaxe dans la relation
avec l'excellent affaire à suivre donc
merci à vous deux pierre martin et
françois chauvancy d'avoir été avec nous
en direct sur rt france ce soir et on le
disait on
conseil des ministres franco-allemand
aujourd'hui à l'elysée il a lieu par
visioconférence pandémie oblige ce sera
le dernier pour angela merkel qui quitte
ses fonctions à l'automne après quinze
années avec l'aide de l'allemagne
comme chaque année les différents
ministres vont devoir rendre compte du
travail qui a été fait en bilatéral chez
eux et pour en parler nous sommes avec
un claude blanchemaison expert en
relations internationales est bon soir
claude blanchemaison merci d'être avec
nous alors tout d'abord la première
réaction d' emmanuel macron et angela
merkel à l'issue d'un conseil des
ministres franco allemand concerne ceux
dont on vient de parler à l'instant
cette affaire d'espionnage l'europe se
devait de réagir vite
oui bien sûr parce que on le dit souvent
tout le monde écoute tout le monde et
les grands pays
parfois aidées par des pays plus petit
et coûte un petit peu tout le monde
mais avec les moyens techniques dont ils
disposent et les responsables politiques
des différents états les responsables
diplomatiques en principe dispose de
moyens de communications cryptées et
avec les progrès techniques actuelles
certains codes sont impossibles à casser
cela dit à partir du moment où quelqu'un
affichent publiquement qu'il a coopéré
pour écouter un dirigeant évidemment ils
étaient cent il est évidemment
nécessaire de protester c'est
inacceptable dans accepté le principe
mais les écoutes sont absolument
généralisé de la part de beaucoup de
pays
à telle enseigne que la difficulté est
souvent de les archiver de les conserver
et le savoir ce que l'on en fait donc là
on a un problème qui est que la
révélation a été faite sur la place
publique et que par conséquent bien
entendu monsieur macro et madame merkel
sont dans l'obligation de réagir et de
demander des explications aux états unis
d'amérique et au danemark
la chancelière dont une qui présidait
pour la dernière fois son conseil des
ministres franco-allemand avec emmanuel
macron ce conseil justement est ce que
c'est une rencontre purement formelle ou
ou la véritable l'assurance d'une
coopération suivi on pourrait croire que
c'est formel puisque ces rencontres ont
un rythme annuel
depuis que le président chirac et le
chancelier schröder les avait créée en
2003 est effectivement surtout en
période de pandémie où l'on voit les
deux équipes nationales réuni chacune
dans leur capital mais en réalité ça
n'est pas la réelle et ça ne correspond
pas à ce qui se passe en réalité puisque
comme vous l'avez dit chaque binôme
ministériel doit faire le point sur les
progrès qui ont été accomplis par
rapport à la réunion précédente et par
conséquent ça veut dire que chaque
ministre demande à son administration de
faire le point ça veut dire qu'en amour
il ya eu des rencontres bilatérales au
niveau des fonctionnaires au niveau des
ministres et que du côté allemand comme
du côté français les administrations
sont mobilisés et en effet la
coopération franco allemande dans tous
les domaines est très importante et
souvent portent sur des sujets assez
technique
il y avait aujourd'hui une bonne
douzaine de ministres de chaque côté on
le voyait lors de la conférence de
presse tout à l'heure les ministres les
plus importants étaient là quel bilan
peut-on faire de cette relation durant
quatre ans entre la chancelière et le
président français vient je crois
d'abord que la chancelière et le
président français ont appris à se faire
confiance
tout simplement parce que ils savent
aussi que la la la coopération entre la
france et l'allemagne est absolument
essentiel qu'elle est dans l'intérêt de
chacun des deux pays
alors le grand succès naturellement de
cette coopération a été le plan de
relance européenne qui a été décidé en
mai de l'année dernière avec un montant
de 750 milliards d'euros qui ensuite a
été reformulée par la commission
européenne et avec beaucoup de
difficulté d'ailleurs adoptée par les
autres états membres puis avalisé plus
récemment par le parlement européen un
an finalement ça n'est pas beaucoup pour
mettre en oeuvre une novation de cette
importance puisque ça veut dire que dès
le mois de juin
la commission européenne va pouvoir
emprunter sur les marchés mondiaux
grande première
elle va pouvoir utiliser sa capacité
d'emprunt qui est considérable et qui
jusqu'à présent était gelée elle n'avait
pas le droit de l'utiliser pour prêter
ou donner des fonds aux états membres
correspondant aux plans qui ont été
présentés par les états mans qui ont été
discutées et avalisés ensuite à
bruxelles
donc ça c'est un succès franco allemand
et il y a deux ans une telle hypothèse
était parfaitement inimaginable on peut
penser qu emmanuel macron avec les
arguments financiers a convaincu la
chancelière qui elle est une
scientifique et qui comprend les
arguments techniques
elle a très rapidement vu qu'il fallait
relancer l'économie européenne
il fallait une forme de solidarité est
une forme de communautarisation de cette
nouvelle dette c'est-à-dire de l'emprunt
qui allait être fait sur le marché sur
le marché international on voit donc
aussi qu' il ya une culture commune qui
se développent et par exemple lorsque le
président macron parle d'identité
stratégiques européennes dans le domaine
international
cette expression ne plaît pas beaucoup
aux allemands parce qu'ils ont peur que
ça soit dirigée contre le lien
transatlantique
mais finalement on s'aperçoit que tout
le monde peut être l'accord autour du
titre de souveraineté européenne et par
conséquent là encore on peut ménager les
susceptibilités en voyant quels sont les
points qui irrite le partenaire et il y
alla donc une longue pratique que le
président macron et la chancelière ont
repris la chancelière le fait depuis
longtemps elle l'a fait avec plusieurs
prêteurs de la république française et
le président macron a bien utilisés je
pense cet instrument puisqu'il ya eu ce
succès marquant l'année dernière alors
évidemment maintenant il faut préparer
la suite merci on suivra ça évidemment
merci claude blanchou maison expert en
relations internationales rester avec
nous dans quelques instants
nous parlerons des conférences
organisées par le conseil russe pour les
affaires internationales l'ambassadeur
du portugal et la délégation de l'ue à
moscou le chef de la diplomatie russe se
dit prêt à reprendre des relations
normales avec l'europe met sur un pied
d'égalité
et puis direction ensuite israël encore
beaucoup d'obstacles avant la formation
d'un gouvernement
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus une pauvre
de défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre la peuplent
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on sort du qualité
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
des sous les libéraux uniforme c'est
quand même des hommes comment ces
mecs-là arrive à dormir la nuit là aussi
je pense qu'on a vécu quelque chose
dignité gilet jaune c'était des valeurs
de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
des gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas là l'oubli
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct
il y a quand même la liberté je vous
remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
il semble qu'il existe une architecture
naturel reposant sur le pli quel
avantage la nature aux rétais la
pratique et l'origami et comment
peut-elle produire des schémas de pliage
aussi complexe l'évolution a dû revenir
les systèmes de plis paul heureux parce
que cela permet de développer de très
grandes surfaces à l'intérieur de tout
petits espaces
comment imaginer que le pliage d'une
simple surfaces planes nous porte vers
la découverte d'un code universel de la
nature 20h30 heure française soyez les
bienvenus en direct sur rt france
direction à présent moscou se tient
aujourd'hui une conférence sur les
relations entre la russie et l'union
européenne un événement organisé par le
conseil et russe pour les affaires
internationales
l'ambassade du portugal et la délégation
de lieu à moscou on retrouve notre
correspondante à moscou
verhaeghe hoffman bonsoir verra comment
la russie wattel ses relations avec
l'union européenne nous connaissons une
crise de confiance particulièrement
aiguë avec une démolition des mécanismes
de coopération a indiqué le chef de la
diplomatie russe sergueï lavrov
il a également regretté que l'union
européenne est décidé de s'isoler de la
russie je vous propose d'écouter
l'union européenne a décidé de s'isoler
de la russie en reproduisant en même
temps des déclarations selon lesquelles
ce sont nous qui ne respectons pas lieu
et nous efforçons de diviser l'europe
unie en privilégiant des liens
bilatéraux avec les pays membres de l'ue
eux
je tiens à souligner une fois encore si
n'importe quel pays européen est
intéressé par des contacts avec nous et
bien évidemment nous ne suivrons pas de
tels contacts et j'espère que bruxelles
le comprends parfaitement bien
je me plais commence nos premiers mois
actuellement des sanctions illégitime
unilatérales imposées selon le principe
d'attribution arbitraire
à la discrétion de l'union européenne se
multiplient contre notre pays
des allégations sans fondement de type
ilike lice ont préféré à un dialogue
basé sur des faits et la présomption
d'innocence a été remplacé par la
présomption de culpabilité tout
simplement par définition le ministre a
également ajouté que la russie était
prête et intéressés à normaliser les
relations avec l'union européenne
et là cependant souligné que la russie
n'était prête à reprendre les relations
normales que sur un pied d'égalité
alors verra quelle est l'explication
justement selon sergueï lavrov d'un tel
comportement de la part de mieux tout
simplement selon sergueï lavrov l'europe
a perdu son indépendance et le sens de
la réalité
le ministre a également regretté
l'emprise américaine sur le continent
européen
je vous propose d'écouter son jeu mais
malheureusement je constate que le
parapluie américain a fait que les
européens ont perdu leur indépendance
est tout simplement le sens de la
réalité leur capacité à évaluer d'une
manière adéquate les nouveaux défis qui
se posent ainsi que les meilleurs moyens
d'y répondre du point de vue de leurs
intérêts et des intérêts fondamentaux
communs de l'europe
sergueï lavrov a également déploré que
l'europe cauchemar entre lui le temps se
fasse sur la base d'une hostilité envers
la russie alors vérargues at il un moyen
en définitive d'améliorer l'état des
relations entre la russie et l'union
européenne selon la saga d'abord selon
le ministre russe
afin de se sortir de ce cercle vicieux
d'aliénation mutuel il faut s'écouter et
s'entendre prendre conscience de
l'avenir du continent européen enfin le
chef de la diplomatie russe a invité à
rompre avec la logique des sanctions
pour un dialogue honnête dans le respect
mutuel
merci verhaeghe hoffman en direct de
moscou
et pour approfondir le sujet nous sommes
avec pierre laurin journaliste
spécialiste de la russie bonsoir
un grand merci d'être avec nous on vient
d'entendre des relations normales mais
sur un pied d'égalité c'est ce que
demande la russie vis-à-vis de l'europe
une illusion qu à quoi aux sanctions par
exemple je crois que ce que veut dire le
ministre lavrov c'est qu'il faut mettre
les relations à plat je proposais les
problèmes sur la table et essayer de les
résoudre
1 1 mais en oubliant la logorrhée des
sanctions actuellement mais des
sanctions surtout dès qu' il y à un
incident quelque chose qui ne plaît pas
on met des sanctions mais on l'aimé sans
même être sûr de ce qui est s'est
réellement passé
je prends un exemple c'est l'expulsion
de 18 diplomates russes de tchéquie il y
à un mois
les tchèques ne sont pas sûrs que
réellement la russie ait eu quelque
chose à voir avec les la raison invoquée
c'est à dire l'explosion d'un dépôt
d'armes qui n'était pas un dépôt d'armes
officiel mais clandestins en 2014 c'est
à dire que ça remonte à loin
et soudain voilà on a des informations
ne sais pas d'où elles viennent
vale semblablement des états unis et la
tchéquie décide d'excusés 18 diplômes m
c'est ça qui qu'il faut que je crois
m'être mettre un terme à cela il faut
mettre à plat les problèmes discutés et
à partir de là on peut trouver des
solutions ou bien constater
qu'effectivement il ya eu une mésentente
mais dans ce cas les choses sont claires
donc l'égalité c'est ça c'est mettre les
choses d'une manière correcte en face à
face et essayer de résoudre les
problèmes
la question qui se pose et c est ce que
les états membres de l'union européenne
puisque là il ne s'agit pas de l'union
européenne dans son ensemble même si
elle édicte des sanctions
mais c'est la relation bilatérale qui
s'impose est la relation bilatérale peu
dépassé le cadre justement bilatérale
pour engager l'ensemble de l'union
européenne
et ça c'est une autre phase donc c'est
pour ça que le ministre lavrov a été
très réticent lorsque il est question de
négocier directement avec l'union
européenne l'union européenne n'a pas à
lui dicter avec qui elle va parler en
europe et en particulier là on voit très
bien que le portugal s'est décidée à
avoir une position un peu dissonante
même si la délégation de l'union
européenne est également présente mais
le fait qu'il y ait un état européen qui
prennent une initiative pour aller dans
le sens de la rencontre avec la russie
c'est assez positif
alors c'est vrai que cette diplomatie
mise à mal par plusieurs affaires qui
obscurcissent un petit peu le ciel entre
ces russes et les européens ces
européens essaient russe la ferme label
ni la biélorussie également est ce que
il y aura la volonté selon vous de des
membres de l'union européenne d'avoir la
même relation d'égalité que souhaite
moscou pour le moment il est clair que
certains membres oui mais ils sont
relativement rares mais l'union
européenne dans les mêmes non évidemment
la seule chose qui peut faire changer
les choses à mon avis ça va changer
c'est la rencontre entre le président
américain joe biden et le président
russe le dit mir poutine le 16 juin en
suisse parce que la rai semblablement la
donne politique entre les états unis et
la russie va changer non pas
radicalement bien entendu mais
simplement il va y avoir des éléments de
dialogue qui vont apparaître
et ces éléments de dialogue sur les
affaires internationales sur le
désarmement sont très importants pour
les deux pays
et là on se trouve dans une sorte
dynamique qui peut engendrer d'autres
choses c'est à dire que à partir du
moment où le dialogue s'instaure il peut
se produire la même chose qui s'était
produit dans les années 60 entre les
états unis et l'union soviétique
c'est à dire arriver à une forme de
détente et la détente et les
relativement simple à instaurer
aujourd'hui on se rend compte avec cette
histoire d'espionnage des des dirigeants
européens par les états unis avec la
complicité du danemark que les dirty
tricks les sales coups ne sont pas
seulement du côté russe tout le monde
les pratiques
c'est à dire que c'est très bien que
l'union européenne dénonce ce qui se
passe en russie certains événements que
là que les états unis fassent de même
tout cela impeccable mais à condition
qu'il valait un peu de vent devant leur
porte aussi donc là les choses sont
peut-être en train de 2,2 s'égaliser et
je crois que après le 18 le pardon le 16
juin
il y aura certainement une le début
d'une dynamique entre la russie et les
etats unis il faut que l'union
européenne soit présente parce que sinon
elle va se retrouver largué
merci beaucoup pierre laurin merci
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france spécialiste de la russie
après une crise diplomatique l'an
dernier leur est un fragile apaisement
entre la grèce et la turquie le
président turc est le premier ministre
grec se rencontreront le mois prochain
les chefs de la diplomatie des deux pays
ont annoncé dans la foulée de leur
entrevue aujourd'hui à athènes
les explications de françois xavier
lambert une rencontre pour apaiser les
relations compliquées entre la grèce et
la turquie
les chefs de la diplomatie des deux pays
se sont rencontrés à athènes pour
évoquer leurs dissensions
et la prochaine rencontre de leurs
dirigeants le 14 juin prochain à
l'occasion du sommet de l'otan des
discussions qui ont permis de relancer
le dialogue entre ankara et athènes nous
sommes pleinement conscients de nos
différents et sérieux problèmes liés aux
positions différentes que nous incarnons
ici nous et la turquie avec le but de
notre réunion d'aujourd'hui était de
tenter un premier processus de
consultation et si possible de
normaliser progressivement la situation
au fil du temps nous avons commencé à
travailler sur des projets concrets axé
sur l'action et la coopération
nous avons trouvé un accord en 25 points
désormais nos institutions compétentes
se réuniront pour travailler sur une
variété de domaines de coopération
un large éventail allant du transport à
l'énergie du tourisme à l'environnement
et aux commerces
si ces discussions semblent avoir apaisé
les tensions
la visite du chef de la diplomatie
turque avait commencé par une polémique
arrivé en thrace occidentale mais
wluczka vous oglou a rencontré les
représentants de la minorité musulmane
locale une communauté dont le statut
divise les deux pays sur le plan
historique
les musulmans de la région ont obtenu le
statut de minorité en grèce suite au
traité de lausanne signé en 1923 et qui
mettait un terme à la guerre de l'époque
entre les deux pays mais pour ankara le
gouvernement grec ne respecte pas
correctement les droits de cette
minorité
sur twitter mais bhl ou de caves ou
zouglou a ravivé les tensions en grèce
pour rencontrer des membres de la
minorité turque de thrace occidentale et
discuter de nos relations bilatérales
j'ai souligné que nous nous tiendrons
toujours résolument aux côtés de la
minorité turque dans sa lutte pour ses
droits et j'ai souligné une fois de plus
notre ferme soutien
ce tweet a été pris comme une nouvelle
provocation par la grèce un mois après
une conférence de presse déjà tendu sur
le sujet entre mais vous deux cas vous
oglou et son homologue grec pour athènes
cette minorité musulmane et pleinement
intégré à la grèce la minorité musulmane
de thrace compte environ 120 milles
habitants grecque
les tentatives constante de la turquie
de déformer cette réalité ainsi que les
allégations de non protection des droits
de ses citoyens ou de discrimination
sont sans fondement et sont rejetés dans
leur intégralité
cette polémique survient alors que les
relations entre les deux pays se sont
fortement dégradées ces derniers mois
l'an dernier
la turquie avait envoyé un navire
prospecter du gaz dans les eaux proches
de la côte turque des eaux revendiquées
par la grèce mais le principal sujet de
friction demeurent la question
migratoire athènes accuse ankara de ne
rien faire pour empêcher les migrants de
gagner ses côtes
de leur côté les turcs dénonce les
traitements inhumains que leur
infligerait les garde-côtes grecs
c'est un ralliement qui pourrait bien
pousser mamie netanyahu vers la sortie
naftali bennet chef de file de la droite
radicale israélienne négocié les termes
de son rapprochement avec yi he lépine
le centriste qui pourrait être en mesure
de former un nouveau gouvernement avec
encore d'autres partis politiques à
meillassoux blé avec valentin carpentier
naftali bennet main dans la main avec
haïr lapide c'est cette coalition
gouvernementale qui pourrait mettre fin
aux douze années de pouvoir de benyamin
netanyahou leader du parti et sha tin
yaïr lapid est chargé de former un
gouvernement en raison de l'échec du
premier ministre à le faire après le
dernier scrutin législatif de mars
dernier où lendemain de cette alliance
il s'est dit prêt à faire face aux
obstacles qu'il attend jusqu'à la
formation du gouvernement prévu il ya
beaucoup d'obstacles à venir c'est
peut-être une bonne chose car nous
devrons les surmonter ensemble c'est
notre premier test pour voir si nous
pouvons trouver des compromis
intelligent pour le grand objectif dans
les jours à venir
ce dimanche naftali bennet leader du
parti de droite radicale yamina a
annoncé son intention de s'allier à la
formation centriste
monsieur netanyahou ne sait plus de
former un gouvernement de droite car il
sait très bien qu'il n'y en a pas il
veut amener l'ensemble du bloc national
l'ensemble de l'état son dernier combat
personnel dans un moment aussi décisif
il faut faire preuve de responsabilité
c'est pourquoi j'annonce aujourd'hui que
j'ai l'intention de faire tout mon
possible pour former un gouvernement
d'unité nationale avec mon ami yaïr
lapid afin que si dieu le veut nous
puissions ensemble sauver le pays de la
dérive et remettent israël sur le droit
chemin mais des numéros de série sera la
marque lola ancien conseiller de
benyamin nétanyahou naftali bennett qui
a réalisé un faible score lors des
dernières élections législatives revient
sur le devant de la scène
il pourrait permettre à son allié du
centre de réunir les 61 députés
nécessaires pour former une majorité au
parlement
l'actuel premier ministre déplore ce
projet de coalition qu'il estime trop à
gauche
bennett induit à nouveau le public en
erreur les mêmes mensonges et slogans
vides sur la haine et la division de la
part de celui qui donne sa main à la
haine et la division et aussi de celui
qui mène un acte du siècle je lance un
appel à mes amis qui ont été élus par
des électeurs de droite ceux qui ont une
conscience des valeurs ne formaient pas
un gouvernement de gauche ce
gouvernement est une menace pour la
sécurité d'israël est pour l'avenir du
pays
une coalition qui impliquerait de grands
sacrifices pour certains partis de
gauche selon nathalie bennett qui
pourrait être promu chef du gouvernement
alors que le poste de ministre de la
justice reviendrait également un homme
de droite guidéon saar
en rejoignant la coalition naftali
bennet assume sa position anti netanyahu
le likoud au pouvoir depuis des années
pourrait donc connaître un net recul sur
la scène politique israélienne alors
même que le pays s'apprête à voter ce
mercredi pour élire un nouveau président
érection tel aviv d'habitants qui se
montre divisée face à ce projet de
coalition
il n'y a pas d'autres moyens
l'avenir nous oblige à ce que tout le
monde se rassemble pour un avenir
meilleur
d'autres je soutiens le gouvernement
d'unité je veux que tous les partis de
toutes les parties politiques s'unissent
et formats bon gouvernement
les haras peuvent rejoindre le
gouvernement si les questions de
sécurité et d'autres choses importantes
restent entre nos mains la pire chose
qui se soit passé en israël en 70 ans et
ce gouvernement
ce gouvernement de fraude et de
tricherie ils ont pris nos votes d'un
côté et les ont donné de l'autre côté
c'est comme si nous avions été vendues
sans savoir comment nous avons voté pour
bennett et nous aurons un gouvernement
lapide pas plus de précisions nous
retrouvons tout de suite en direct paula
slayer journalistes pour rt
internationale en direct
bonsoir paula merci d'être avec nous
vous êtes notre correspondante sur place
à deux jours de l'échéance pour former
un gouvernement
rien ne semble joué n'est ce pas
effectivement les joueurs en israël a
peu changé la donne en matière de
politique là puis mercredi la piste et
je suis la petite chatte de l'opposition
avant donc ce mercredi
je suis la guide doit présenter à
reouven rivlin le majorité de coalition
pour le moment effectivement et la
majorité puis l'a 61 61 députés sur 120
à la knesset
si la collation tient toujours mercredi
relève et il pourra dire au président je
te former le prochain gouvernement
mais effectivement tout n'est pas joué
car le clown ministre actuel premier
ministre netanyahou ni ne devra
acquitter les pouvoirs que une mardi
prochain donc ce que la semaine
prochaine dans marty que le scénario
sera intégré car au cours de ce laps de
temps
si je vous dis n'importe lequel des 61
membres de cette nouvelle coalition
l'abandonnent alors il n'y aura plus de
majorité et le pays devra se rendre à
nouveau aux urnes
[Musique]
il ya beaucoup de réunions en coulisses
de winnie sous deux ministres et
potentiels établissant les demandes ce
qu'ils souhaitent tâche et le dirigeant
de l'opposition
yaïr lapid essaye de gérer tout cela
afin de conserver cette majorité de 61
sur 120 sièges alors des rivaux on peut
lire idéologiquement très disparates qui
se rapprochent ils n'ont qu'un but en
fait déloger gbagbo
yahoo ce sont des alliés très étrange
la bid chef de l'opposition est au
centre gauche de l'échiquier politique
israélien et il s'allie avec quels
moyens
un chef de la droite naftali bennet chef
du parti yami no 6 ce qui signifie parti
de droite s'est également l'ancien
ministre de la défense d'israël au sein
de cette commission on trouve également
les partis arabes israéliens hormis
naftali bennett qui est à droite ça et
les partis arabes à gauche n'ont
absolument rien en commun notamment en
regard de ce récent conflit entre le
hamas et israël
il tenait à l'époque que de chez bell
est net à l'époque des propos très âpres
sur la qualité arabe et déclamatoire
gloire former un gouvernement avec donc
effectivement des alliances est très
étrange qui montre bien le niveau des
divisions au sein du pays et comme vous
l'avait bien dit ce qui les rassemble
c'est l'opposition à netanyahu
mais tout cela pourrait ne pas suffire à
maintenir cette coalition provisoire
l'un des pronostics en israël qui sait
que même si la semaine prochaine
ils réussissent un former un
gouvernement alors il ne durera sont
deux fois plus longtemps que quelques
mois du fait de ses vues politiques
extrêmement disparates
après justement cette alliance un peu
contre nature by nintendo a mis en garde
contre un danger pour la sécurité de
l'état d'israël il a parlé d' ailleurs
d' arnaque du siècle
cette alliance met-elle vraiment en
danger l'état hébreu demande à certains
israéliens ils se
trahi par naftali bennett qui rejoint
une coalition de centre gauche
on demande des personnes plutôt à gauche
elle trouve fantastique que doivent
enfin quitter le pouvoir et ils pensent
que capitale issa ont trouvé un accord
avec eux deux ans au pouvoir pour
naftali bennet puis deux ans avec gears
l'habite et les gens pensent que l'umq
cela sera le gouvernement dont israël a
besoin cela dépend donc à qui on demande
la plupart des israéliens sont d'accord
pour dire que quatre élections en
l'espace de deux ans c'est trop si la
coalition ne tient pas jusqu'à mardi de
la semaine prochaine
alors il devrait y avoir des nouvelles
élections donc seulement ne soutient pas
cette nouvelle coalition mais je pense
que la majorité des israéliens ne
soutiendrait pas l'idée d'une cinquième
élection et c'est le raisonnement qu'a
avancé 1 à staline est pour expliquer
cette pollution dix ans sortons de cette
crise politique
mettons un terme à ces élections
récurrente pour la mélamine athènes et
où peut-il encore s'en sortir dans le
contexte actuel il écoute
c'est effectivement une possibilité
cette coalition qui se fanent compris
pourrait excuser ils ont 61 sièges
il pourrait en pack de nancy peña ming
netanyahu tu n'as pas de majorité avec
simplement 50 sièges alors il y aura de
nouvelles élections après 6,6 la
collection ne tient pas et dans une can
you pourrait réussir à former une
coalition
la seule manière de pouvoir être ré
pour gagner montagna où seraient d'une
nouvelle sélection car il a pas réussi à
former de nouvelles conditions et il a
tenu un discours hier soir avertissant
que cette coalition était très
dangereuse dans cette gare est l'allié
des éléments de gauche et de droite
il veut expliquer que ce gouvernement je
ne pourrais pas prendre de décisions sur
des décisions polémiques tels que le
processus de paix
du fait de leur différence c'est le
nouveau gouvernement alors il serait
plus susceptible de se concentrer sur la
sortie de lakovic l'économie et le
maintien du cessez le feu entre hamas et
israël
il ne serait selon benyamin nétanyahou
pas capable de traiter des sujets
difficiles du fait de la disparité est
des points de vue au sein de cette
coalition qui espère être le nouveau
gouvernement
merci pour la seigneur journalistes pour
rt internationale en direct de tel aviv
à rester avec nous donc quelques
instants noms viendront en france où le
conseil constitutionnel valide le passé
ni terre pour les grands rassemblements
à côté vaccination est désormais ouverte
à toute personne majeure en france et
puis direction le royaume uni où les
chercheurs alerte sur les possibles aux
prémices d'une troisième vague
[Musique]
il
le ms a exhorté certains pays africains
à ne pas détruire les vaccins anti
qu'ovide périmés il faut craindre une
vaccination low cost en afrique nos une
vaccination à l'est une vaccination
savez la vaccination ce n'est pas elle
n'a pas commencé avec la ville-etat le
problème ça reste quand même
l'approvisionnement est ce que c'est la
faute des pays les plus riches qui
accapare justement les production de
vaccins
où est le mécanisme de la vaccination
vous savez ça a soulevé beaucoup danger
sur la question de la solidarité si on
peut en faire plus en terme de
solidarité de partage
c'est là c'est quelque chose
d'absolument importants ainsi que le
nigeria affirme qu'il élabore son propre
vaccin contre le coc u19 pour en finir
avec justement la dépendance vis-à-vis
des laboratoires à l'étranger que ce
soit le sénégal le nigeria l'afrique du
sud
beaucoup de pays en cette ambition-là
devoir amener la générale de la santé
publique au top des priorités c'est
quelque chose que nous saluons
énormément au niveau de l'organisation
mondiale de la santé oms
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez comme moi qui ai des gandhi il n'y
a pas d'alternative au sort du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
déçu l'univers l'uniforme c'est quand
même des hommes comment ces mecs-là
arrive à dormir la nuit là aussi je
pense qu'on a vécu quelque chose
d'inusité gilet jaune c'était des
valeurs de droite
c'était les gens qui travaillent c'est
les gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soient pas publics
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est on dirait qu'il y a quand
même la liberté je vous remercie de
m'avoir invité
[Musique]
une passe maison bleue un patio rempli
de plantes des collections d'art
précolombien des tableaux à profusion
nous étions sur une nouvelle planète
chez frida kahlo et diego rivera la
maison bleue c'est d'abord la maison de
frida kahlo elle y est née en 1907
elle ya grandi elle les a peints ri
pleuré souffert en laissant grandes
ouvertes les portes de sa maison dans
les années 1930 des artistes des
intellectuels des poètes et des espions
trouve refuge à la maison bleue un
village dans la ville
un théâtre nombre
[Musique]
un féminicide et commis tous les deux à
trois jours en france actuellement
pourquoi il sous ton encore à protéger
totalement les femmes on dit souvent aux
femmes
oser en parler briser le silence nous
savons que seulement 18 19 % des femmes
révèle les violences qu'elles subissent
donc ça veut dire qu'il ya 80% de femmes
qui ne révèle pas les violences qu'elles
subissent aux forces de sécurité
donc celle qui rêvait il faut vraiment
les croix et les protéger souvent on met
toute la responsabilité sur la victime
c'est la question de quels sont les
moyens que l'agresseur a mis en oeuvre
qui doit être posée et la loi le dis
très clairement
et souvent on détourne la loi par cette
histoire de consentement on voit bien
qu'on est quand même encore très loin
très loin de ce qui est nécessaire pour
vraiment pouvoir avoir les moyens de
protéger les femmes
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
pour beaucoup le foot a été synonyme
d'évasion durant cette période de la
pandémie
quel est le rôle justement du football
dans notre société en temps de crise je
pense ça a été bien de continuer le
football pour s'évader un peu aussi haut
niveau au niveau mental
on est tous conscients que le football
ligny tout ce qui est au niveau social
surtout au niveau culture et quel regard
portez-vous sur toutes ces années à
monaco à la juventus en équipe de france
le football le football c'est ma vie et
le football m'a beaucoup donné en entend
tous les contextes et quand on a la
chance de revenir en étant ambassadeur
boire les gens
nous reconnaître les choses qu'on a fait
mais surtout au niveau du beau football
et ça c'est touchant
[Musique]
21h bonsoir à tous merci nous rejoindre
pour cette deuxième heure d'émission
tout de suite voici des titres de
l'actualité de ce lundi 31 mai feu vert
du conseil constitutionnel sur le projet
controversé du pass sanitaire la
vaccination désormais ouverte à toute
personne majeure en france
emmanuel macron lui annonce sur twitter
avoir été vaccinés la vaccination une
étape décisive pour éviter un rebond
d'épidémie ces prochains mois l'exécutif
redoute pourtant un plafond de verre et
s'interroge sur les moyens de convaincre
les réfractaires
[Musique]
outre-manche les cas positifs ou
coronavirus repartent à la hausse pour
la première fois depuis janvier une
situation sanitaire qui s'explique par
la dominance du banian indien selon le
conseil scientifique britannique
le gouvernement qui espère bien retarder
l'arrivée de cette troisième vague grâce
à la vaccination est entamée le 21 juin
sa dernière étape du déconfinement
[Musique]
coup de sang de monsieur patrimoine
stéphane bern a signé hier une tribune
au vitriol contre la ministre de la
transition écologique et mon contrat je
cite la véritable calamité écologique
que constitue l'implantation abusive et
anarchique des éoliennes terrestres ou
en mer un sujet qui fait réagir des
politiques de tous bords alors l'énergie
éolienne si elle a le vent en poupe at
elle vraiment de l'avenir ce sera
l'objet de notre face à face ce soir
[Musique]
le feu vert du conseil constitutionnel
au pass annie terre il sera utilisé pour
les rassemblements de plus de 1000
personnes comme les festivals
il permettra de justifier d'un test pcr
négative d'un justificatif de
vaccination ou d'une attestation de
rétablissement après une contamination
et sur le front de la vaccination
justement emmanuel macron annoncé sur
twitter avoir été vaccinés depuis ce
matin tous les français de plus de 18
ans peuvent recevoir une injection
antico vite sans critère particulier
mais avec 28 millions d'adultes
éligibles à la vaccination et non
vaccinés il faudra s'armer encore de
patience à chaque jour ce sont en
moyenne 500 milles rendez-vous qui sont
disponibles pour se faire vacciner
toutes les demandes ne pourront donc pas
être accepté tout de suite
cela n'en reste pas moins une étape
cruciale pour éviter un rebond de
l'épidémie ce qui réjouit jean castex en
déplacement ce matin dans un centre de
vaccination à saint-maur-des-fossés dans
le val-de-marne 25 millions et demi de
nos concitoyens adultes qui ont
bénéficié d'une primo vaccination vous
savez j'ai fixé un objectif d'être à 30
millions à la mi juin je le dis cet
objectif est à notre portée nous avons
reçu je le rappelle 12 millions de doses
de vaccins mad avril 15 millions mois du
maire qui se termine
nous allons 27 millions au mois de juin
alors bien sûr au mois de juin on va
voir monter et c'est très heureux le
nombre de deuxième injection
mais il faut vacciner
tous azimuts l'arrivée de ces deux le
permet la mobilisation et la remarquable
organisation des centres de vaccination
rendre tout cela possible et l'exécutif
qui cherche aussi à convaincre les
réfractaires à la vaccination sont
encore nombreux en france
la rendre obligatoire ferait partie des
options scarlett pas un plafond de verre
plane au dessus de la campagne vaccinale
premiers signes inquiétants la courbe
des vaccinés chez les plus de 70 ans ne
progresse pratiquement plus le monsieur
vaccin du gouvernement reconnaît le
problème
nous savons aujourd'hui que quelques
groupes ne sont pas aussi bien vacciné
qu'ils le devraient
un quart des plus de 80 ans n'a toujours
pas reçu d'injection alors qu'ils
étaient parmi les premiers à pouvoir en
bénéficier
au ministère de la santé ont confié être
arrivé dans cette catégorie d'âge a une
limite celle des sceptiques
c'est bien la principale menace qui
plane sur cette campagne de vaccination
les anti vaccins ou les simples
réfractaires d'après une étude de
l'agencé santé publique france du 7 mai
dernier
44% des personnes interrogées affirmé ne
pas vouloir se faire vacciner pour les
convaincre le gouvernement travaille
de nouvelles campagnes de communication
devront toucher spécifiquement les
jeunes qui se sentent moins vulnérables
aux formes graves de la maladie et les
classes populaires qui ont d'autres
préoccupations que locaux vides
l'autre facteur qui pourrait diminuer le
nombre de candidats à la vaccination
l'arrivée des vacances d'été le danger
c'est qu'on ne parle plus du coc vides
et qu au coeur de l'été les gens ne
pensent plus à se faire vacciner
nous devons anticiper ce phénomène le
gouvernement envisage trois solutions
pour en limiter d'un pagne envoyé plus
de doses dans les zones les plus
touristiques rendre possible injection
de la seconde dose sur les lieux de
vacances et revoir le délai de six
semaines entre la première et la
deuxième injection
près de 40 % de la population a reçu au
moins une dose de sérum anti qu'ovide
mais pour atteindre l'immunité
collective
l'académie de médecine a revu des
chiffres à la hausse pour sortir
durablement de la crise sanitaire
il faudrait que 90 % des adultes ou 80 %
de la population totale dont des enfants
soient vaccinés avant l'automne pour
atteindre cet objectif la vaccination
pourraient être ouverts avant l'été aux
moins de 18 ans l' agence européenne des
médicaments a d'ailleurs donné son feu
vert vendredi dernier pour vacciner les
12 15 ans avec le sérum pfizer bio ntech
c'est aussi pour arriver à une immunité
suffisante que l'académie de médecine a
recommandé mardi dernier de rendre la
vaccination obligatoire pour certaines
professions ou encore pour les étudiants
pour la rentrée scolaire de 2021
une piste plus radical que le
gouvernement avait initialement écarté
mais jeudi dernier
emmanuel macron a affirmé qu'aucune
porte n'était fermée
à l'heure où la vaccination s'ouvre à
tous les majeurs le gouvernement tient à
rassurer la demande excède encore
l'offre de vaccins et parmi les
départements qui accuse le plus de
retard dans la vaccination la seine
saint denis où seulement de 10 % avait
achevé son parcours au vaccinale 23 mai
contre 16 % au niveau national
reportage luc alléger sur place début
avril le stade de france a été
transformée en grande pompe en centre de
vaccination géant depuis ce
vaccinodromes est le symbole des efforts
des autorités françaises pour atteindre
l'immunité collective en mettant le
paquet sur les populations les plus
pauvres et les plus vulnérables a mais
depuis force est de constater que la
vaccination prend du retard
en seine-saint-denis le 23 mai seuls 9,5
pour cent de la population était
totalement vaccinés contre près de 16% à
paris intra muros au même moment chez
les personnes âgées de 75 ans et plus
ils étaient 58,10 % à être totalement
vacciner un des chiffres les plus bas de
france contre 68,9 pour cent à paris et
si on descend dans les âges l'écart se
creuse le taux de moins de 55 ans de
paris intra muros ayant reçu une
première injection est deux fois plus
élevé que celui de seine-saint-denis
le taux de vaccination en seine saint
denis selon les populations cibles est
inférieur de 7 à 11 points de la moyenne
nationale déficit d'information mauvaise
compréhension du français chez certains
habitants méfiance envers les autorités
plusieurs hypothèses sont avancées pour
expliquer cet écart pour régler le
problème
la rs et la préfecture ont demandé aux
élus locaux de renforcer la
communication auprès des plus isolés dès
ce week end la seine saint denis est
doté de quinze mille doses de vaccins
supplémentaires et recevra 120 mille
doses de vaccin hebdomadaire au mois de
juin le préfet demande également aux
élus et aux associations de la politique
de la ville de renforcer leur opération
de sensibilisation à la vaccination des
populations les plus précaires et de
remobiliser les centres communaux
d'action sociale pour qu ils multiplient
les actions auprès des personnes les
plus éloignées du système de soins
parallèlement plusieurs centres ont été
ouverts et des consignes ont été données
pour offrir des conditions plus flexible
notamment avec des possibilités à
certains endroits d'être vacciné sans
rendez vous quant au stade de france
ils ferment désormais à 21h ces mesures
pour rattraper le retard pris mais pour
l'instant c'est la double peine pour la
seine-saint-denis qui avait déjà été un
des départements les plus touchés par la
surmortalité pendant la première vague
de l'épidémie au printemps 2020 et pour
en parler de cette vaccination nous
sommes avec bertrand legrand médecins
généralistes bonsoir verte
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france tout d'abord ce décrochage dans
l'accès aux vaccins en seine saint denis
est ce que c'est de nature à être
inquiétant oui bien sûr que sa nature
est très inquiétant parce que le
gouvernement n'a toujours pas compris
comment on faisait pour faire vacciner
les populations les plus précaires et
les plus à risque on a exclu au maximum
les médecins généralistes de la
vaccination est aujourd'hui là où on a
mis le plus gros centre de france de
vacciner de vaccination le plus grand
rex nos drôme où on a le résultat qui
est le moins bon taux de vaccination il
faut remiser sur les acteurs de
proximité qui sont les médecins
généralistes et je vous rappelle qu'à
cette heure-ci moi je n'ai toujours pas
touché un seul vaccin type kaiser ou
moderna pour jouer actionner des gens de
moins de 55 ans donc si dans les
quartiers populaires les médecins
généralistes ne peuvent pas vacciner
leurs propres patientèle
n'espérez pas qu'elles viennent prendre
un rendez vous sur un compte internet
pour venir alors même qu'elles sont
incapables d'honorer en général le
rendez vous chez l'ophtalmo sont que
c'est pareil ça veut dire pour vous
qu'il ya une partie de la population
voilà qui n'ira jamais dansé
vaccinodromes on peut quand même le dire
pour une fois c'est quand même plutôt
bien organisé
sur place c'est très bien organisé sur
place allaient encore beaucoup mieux et
beaucoup plus efficace chez le médecin
généraliste du patient est ce qu'on voit
c'est qu'aujourd'hui ce sont les
populations les plus aisés le bobo
parisien comme on peut dire qu'ils se
fait vacciner les gens qui sont pressés
de partir en vacances et on voit bien
que dans les couches populaires l'accès
reste extrêmement difficile et c'est
négliger la difficulté de l'accès aux
soins du fait de l'éducation
c'est une constante on pense toujours
qu'il suffit de mettre de l'argent sur
la table pour que les gens se soignent
en réalité ce n'est pas un problème
d'argent c'est souvent un problème
d'éducation
le fait que vous ayez des vaccins
feather et moderna chez les généralistes
est-ce que ça reste du domaine du
possible on a souvent parlé un des
problèmes de de conservation à des
températures très basses est ce que ça
va arriver un jour ce selon vous alors
j'aime votre incantations j'aimerais que
ça arrive
officiellement on est censé recevoir la
semaine dernière mais le tableau le
camion semble être tombé en panne en
tout cas uniquement pour les libéraux
c'est vraiment pas de chance la
conservation banon c'est n'est pas un
problème puisque le kaiser qui était le
plus dur à conserver se retrouvent le
plus facile à conserver
puisqu'on peut le garder 31 jours dans
nos frigos classique j'irai de votre
propre cuisine
donc il n'y a plus rien qui empêche à un
généraliste d'utiliser de garder du
kaiser du moderna dans son cabinet par
contre ce qui nous empêche aujourd'hui
de vacciner les moins de 55 ans c'est
l'idéologie de l'état qui nous empêche à
nous à être doté d'un stock de vaccins
dédié aux personnes de moins de 55 ans
donc à cantonner les médecins
généralistes et les libéraux uniquement
à la vaccination des personnes âgées
effectivement ça risque pas de
progresser chez les récalcitrants le
plafond vert que craignent les autorités
ce serait dû à ça ce que vous nous
décrivez aujourd'hui pour passer le le
stade suivant les j'ose dire
la vaccination était très ouverte à tous
ceux qui le voulaient et on a au moindre
mot négligé mais plutôt je dirais vexé
l'ensemble des acteurs libéraux et
notamment dans leur manière de prise en
charge est effectivement aujourd'hui qui
va aller vacciner
la grand mère de 80 ans qui peut pas se
déplacer dans un centre de vaccination
c'est bien de médecins généralistes ou
son infirmier ou son pharmacien
donc à un moment donné si on ne donne
pas les moyens de le faire si on nous
donne dix vaccins par semaine il faut
pas non plus en même temps se plaindre
que les médecins généralistes ne fasse
pas au entre guillemets le job oblige on
fait pas le job on n'a pas les 12
donc c'est évident emmanuel macron qui
annonce ce soir avoir été vacciné une
réaction
c'est très bien parfait excellente
nouvelle et pas grand chose à rajouter
effectivement l'horizon se dégage en
tout cas comme l'a dit jean castex moins
de 3000 malades en soins critiques
c'est une première quand même depuis fin
janvier cessé de bonhommes qu augure on
voit quand même la sortie du tunnel
dites-nous oui oui c'est d'autant plus
une bonne augure que si on avait vu un
petit plateau il ya une semaine qui
avait l'air de se fixer sur les faons
pour cent mille à personne
le plateau a l'air de redescendre
maintenant ces derniers jours
et donc on peut espérer que on va aller
chercher cette femme plateau
probablement que les isolements se font
un petit peu mieux et j'espère qu'on va
revenir sur ces problématiques
d'isolement car une personne qui est
toujours contagieuses toujours avec plus
de virus dans le nez ne peut pas être
libérée dogmatiquement au bout de dix
jours c'est quelque chose que je répète
depuis le début
et si on veut enfoncer ce socle qui que
l'on traîne depuis septembre il faut
aussi renfoncer l'idéologie qui nous y
amener depuis septembre à savoir l'
isolement de dix jours sans se poser de
questions alors cette décrue alors que
les
les écoles l'école a repris 1 depuis
d'ailleurs plusieurs semaines maintenant
justement on préconise la vaccination le
conseil de la haute autorité de santé
préconise la vaccination des adolescents
et des enfants c'est une bonne chose
selon vous elle est indispensable c'est
nécessité fait loi
on va avoir du mal à atteindre 80 %
d'une population vaccinée sans y mettre
les adolescents parce que ça voudrait
dire qu'on atteint quasiment 100% chez
l'adulte
or on sait très bien qu'on n'y arrive
pas et les moyens qui sont mis en oeuvre
ne sont pas des moyens qui sont de
nature à rassurer sur l'atteinte de cet
objectif là donc encore une fois quand
on fait une vaccination de masse en
vaccinodromes on atteint les 60% 70% de
vacciner maximum on n'atteint pas 80%
donc pour atteindre les 80 90 % qui sont
nécessaires pour ne pas vacciner nos
enfants est très clairement il faudrait
il faudrait que les médecins libéraux
soit à la manoeuvre ce qui n'est pas le
cas donc du coup on va élargir un petit
peu et puis on rendra de plus en plus
insupportable la vie à ceux qui refusent
de se vacciner pour au final le rendre
obligatoire sans le rendre obligatoire
parce que politiquement parlant on peut
pas dire obligatoire donc on trouvera un
nouveau mot mais chut voilà à quoi je
pense que ben ouais mais est très fort
pour inventer de nouveaux baux donc j'ai
leur laisser le choix de deux chevaux
pour préciser c'est la haute autorité de
santé qui doit rendre sa décision et
c'est le conseil scientifique qui
préconise une dernière petite question
est ce que vous craignez en france
la multiplication du variant indien qui
semble beaucoup embêté nos amis
britanniques en ce moment le variant
indien comme tous les autres variant ne
connaît pas de frontières et on peut
toujours imaginer que nous mettons en
place des mesures strictes qui
empêcheront le variant d'arrivée s'il
variant est plus contagieux il va se
diffuser
la seule chose qui va le freiner c'est
la capacité à rencontrer un obstacle cet
obstacle c'est la vaccination
voilà et on n'arrête pas gérer us avec
des mesures que soit arrêté
merci beaucoup bertrand legrand médecin
généraliste à tourcoing merci d'avoir
été avec nous et on le disait justement
outre manche un des chercheurs alerte
sur les signes d'une vague à précoce les
cas positifs au qu'ovide repartent à la
hausse pour la première fois depuis
janvier une situation qui s'explique par
la dominance du variant indien nettement
plus contagieux que la souche initial le
gouvernement qui espère bien retarder
l'arrivée de cette troisième vague grâce
à la vaccination surtout les deuxième
injection
afin d'arriver sereinement la dernière
étape du déconfinement le 21 juin et
pour en parler nous sommes en direct
depuis le royaume-uni avec bharat banque
anja expert en maladies infectieuses à
l'université d'exeter c'est notre
rubrique vu de l'extérieur ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir bar à tapas ocaña merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france ces
derniers jours le nombre de cas positifs
de décès d'hospitalisations a augmenté
de plus de 20% au royaume-uni
des chercheurs alerte désormais c'est le
début d'une troisième vague selon vous
nous espérons que ce n'est pas le cas
mais il faut être très prudent
oui le problème et ce variant plus
contaminant bros wii pour le sketch ci
nous levant les restrictions si elle
mourrait lançons les interactions avec
d'autres personnes
il ya la réapparition de foule de
restauration à l'intérieur alors les
contamination et vont repartir à la
hausse et pour les personnes non
vaccinées ce sera un problème
alors c'est vrai qu'on ne s'y attendait
pas nécessairement parce que le royaume
uni était un vrai exemple pour le reste
des européens
comment vous vous expliquer que malgré
la vaccination le variant indien semble
plus fort les faits reliant apparaissent
n'importe où et invariants conteste il
c'est un vrai problème
le royaume-uni est en avance en matière
de vaccination mais pollue tout le monde
n'a pas été complètement vaccinés oui et
variant circule beaucoup dans certaines
régions et il est plus contagieux pour
les personnes qui ne sont pas pleinement
vacciner notamment pour les personnes
les plus jeunes c'est ce qui pose
problème c'est vraiment le casse-tête la
clé peut-être du problème c'est aussi
l'espace entre les deux doses on
rappelle que ça a été augmentée au
royaume uni pour pouvoir vacciner
davantage de monde
ça devient une mauvaise décision
aujourd'hui ce n'est plus souhaitable de
garder autant d' espaces entre les deux
doses non je ne pense pas que le
problème c'est l'écart entre la première
et la seconde touche où est le problème
c'est ce variant qui est plus contagieux
il est donc plus facile d'être de tomber
malade je deuxième problème c'est la
pression politique calme au 2e tour de
tous les horizons de lever les
restrictions le plus rapidement possible
à partir du 21 juin et le cas scott
c'est que tout le monde n'a pas été
vaccinés donc nous maîtrisons la
situation si et seulement si nous
continuons à bâtir et autant de
personnes que possible même avec une
simple première dose et il faut
maintenir dans le même temps des
restrictions au delà du 21 juin
cela sera dans l'intérêt de la nation
on lit souvent dans la presse que 3 n
est qu un qui représente on le rappelle
une grande partie de la vaccination
royaume uni affiche une efficacité
modérée 1 face aux variants indien est
ce que c'est là aussi que le bât blesse
tout de même non je ne pense pas qu'il
faut s'inquiéter de l'efficacité et
astrazeneca contre les variants et puis
général le vaccin protège le vaccin est
vite les hospitalisations notamment en
nullité de soins intensifs et les décès
donc même si l'on n'est pas totalement
protégé en tout cas elle ne finira pas à
l'hôpital donc cela est toujours le cas
le secret ce
de vacciner autant de personnes que
possible de baisser le niveau des
circulations dans les communautés et
cela rend la communauté dans son
ensemble plus sec plus sécurisée quel
que soit le vaccin utilisé en tant que
l'épidémiologiste est-ce que vous
préconise riez une remise en cause du
déconfinement rappelle que le point
d'orgue doit avoir lieu d'ici quelques
jours d'ici quelques petites semaines le
21 juin au royaume uni oui tout à fait
et les raisons sont les suivantes
tout d'abord nous sommes face à un
variant plus quant à l'union il est donc
plus facile de se retrouver infectés
beaucoup de personnes sont contaminées
alors ces personnes jeunes finiront à
l'hôpital en partie et certaines
personnes mourront même il est donc
important d'adopter la stratégie
suivante à partir d'aujourd'hui aussi
rapidement que possible
il faut développer mais faut enfin deux
axes mais aussi rapidement que possible
et si possible 24 heures sur 24
édité la première injection
- une certaine mesure de protection
s'installe donc cela est une bonne chose
pour la population et on peut commencer
à partir de ce moment-là a levé les
restrictions dans un cadre sécuritaire
bien plus avantageux contre le variant
indien ou toutes autres nouveaux
variants qui apparaîtra à l'avenir un
merci bar à tapas cagna expert en
maladies infectieuses à l'université
d'exeter d'avoir été avec nous en direct
sur rt france ce soir direction l'inde à
présent où la situation sanitaire
s'améliore les nouveaux cas quotidiens
de contamination en kobe baisse
progressivement les restrictions
s'assouplissent donc légèrement à new
delhi la capitale là pour débit et ses
conséquences économiques
elle des milliers d'indiens ont perdu
leur travail une crise alimentaire
émergent dans le pays quand un mot clair
le chemin est encore long mais l'inde
respire de nouveau après un pic à plus
de 414 milka début mai le nombre de
contaminations quotidienne a déjà
diminué de plus de moitié
conséquence la capitale new delhi entame
ce lundi un très léger assouplissement
des restrictions antico vie 19 en place
le secteur de la construction et les
usines pourront reprendre leurs
activités
ne sortez pas sauf si c'est absolument
nécessaire
nous devons être très prudents nous
entamons le processus de réouverture
très très lentement nous le réveillerons
au bout d'une semaine en fonction de
l'avis des experts et de la population
nous rouvrirons lentement tant que le
nombre de cas de kovy 19 ne recommencera
pas à augmenter
nous ne voulons pas d'une situation où
les gens survivent au coronavirus en
mourant de faim
la pandémie a violemment frappé le pays
ces dernières semaines mais un autre
problème inquiète les autorités
la crise alimentaire en cause les pertes
d'emplois liées aux cessations
d'activité de certains secteurs
lors du premier confinement l'an dernier
100 millions d'indiens avaient déjà
perdu leur travail depuis 15 % d'entre
eux n'ont pas réussi à retrouver une
activité
selon une étude de l'université azim
premji début mai les indiens se montrait
désemparé par la nouvelle vague
épidémique et l'appauvrissement de la
population
les pauvres n'ont plus rien on nous
laisse mourir dans les rues que fait le
gouvernement
mafiques et marié souffre de ne pas
pouvoir payer son loyer
même maintenant je vais acheter des
céréales dans les magasins du
gouvernement pour les lieux à porter
tout le monde est confronté à un
problème ou un autre si nous ne prenons
pas de passager ou si nous ne
travaillons pas nous avons des problèmes
et si nous prenons des passagers nous
pourrons également des risques
toujours selon l'université azim premji
230 millions d'indiens serait tomber
dans la pauvreté en 2020 et vivrait avec
l'équivalent de 4 euros 25 par jour
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
nous parlerons du coup de sang de
monsieur patrimoine stéphane bern a
signé une tribune au vitriol sur la
butte l'implantation abusive et des
éoliennes en france alors l'énergie
éolienne
si elle a le vent en poupe at elle
vraiment de l'avenir ce sera l'objet de
notre face à face
[Musique]
si demain un conflit ouvert ce produit
entre la chine et les usa
on peut penser il se déroulera dans la
mer de chine du sud
car cette zone est totalement
stratégique pour les deux ans en 2019
la chine a construit en une année en
plus de bâtiments que les états unis en
quatre en guerre de 1941 à 1945
affichant ainsi sa souveraineté en mer
de chine du sud
pékin fait prévaloir des droits
historiques sur les règles
internationales
quand une puissance dominante constate
qu'elle est en train de se faire
dépasser par une puissance émergente la
tentation normale et de la détruire au
plan politique ou militaire avant
qu'elle n'arrive à ses fins
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
le terme banlieue voir le terme cité
c'est forcément péjoratif c'est vrai que
les médias ont un regard on va dire
assez particulier des banlieues et qui
dérange aujourd'hui et en donnent ces
variations de la banlieue ça se
résoudrait cas des jeunes violents
contre une police qui serait son travail
c'est plus compliqué que ça on est
français on est fiers de vivre dans ces
quartiers même si à des difficultés et
la moindre des choses c'est d'inscrire
aussi notre empreinte canton quand on
participe à la vie de la société et
malheureusement n'y a pas cette
reconnaissance
aujourd'hui je pense que le changement
viendra d'abord à travers cette
conscientisation des citoyens des
quartiers populaires on parle également
des deux zones de reconquête
républicaine
au final derrière ces mots qu'est ce qui
casse qui 6 kg politique fort pour les
gens mais sans les gens c'est à dire qui
donne cette impression de faire de
vouloir changer les choses mais
concrètement politiquement ils ne le
font pas
vous êtes renversé par un homme de 92
ans qui perd le contrôle de son véhicule
deux ans et demi plus tard vous vous
imposez comme un espoir français du
tennis fauteuil objectif est les jeux
paralympiques de paris y sommes le sport
m'a toujours sauver le tennis c'est que
c'est mon sport
bon il ya un fauteuil mais je vais
essayer et en fait je me suis rendu
compte que ça allait c'était
suffisamment physique pour moi j'ai une
vie de sportif de haut niveau je
m'entraîne tous les jours c'est devenu
ma vie la raison de me lever le matin
j'avais toujours ce vieux rêve de petite
fille de faire du sport de ma vie est
finalement là c'est ce que je réalise
avec le jambon manger un autre combat on
ma vie qui est celui de la sécurité
routière s'agit d'un projet de loi qui
vise à mettre en place des tests
d'aptitude pour tous les conducteurs pas
seulement les seniors on a un contrôle
technique de son véhicule
il faut un contrôle technique de sa
personne et sa l'état doit doit imposer
loi sur ce sujet là
[Musique]
21h38 les bienvenus en direct sur rt
francs si vous nous rejoignez les
éoliennes s'invite au sein du débat
électoral
stéphane bern chargé de la mission
patrimoine en péril pour le gouvernement
en signe dans le figaro ce dimanche une
charge contre l'énergie éolienne et s'en
prendre directement à la ministre de la
transition écologique des explications
[Musique]
oh
où
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
où
[Musique]
alors l'énergie éolienne ciel a le vent
en poupe at elle vraiment de l'avenir
est elle vraiment l'énergie du futur une
pollution visuelle ou bien encore un
drame économique annoncée c'est l'objet
de notre face à face avec nous pour en
débattre fabien bouglé experts de
l'éolien à hauteur de éoliennes la face
noire de la transition écologique aux
éditions du rocher bonsoir fabien a
bouclé au côté frédéric lanoë directeur
d'entreprise ancien président de france
énergie éolienne bonsoir j'ai ici
monsieur lannoy et merci d'être avec
nous alors la tribune un de stéphane
bern semble rencontrer un certain écho
auprès des politiques qui vont tous deux
leurs commentaires aujourd'hui les
éoliennes ça devient un sujet éminemment
politique fabien bombes les balles
hautes et oui c'est salutaire la tribune
de stéphane bern est salutaire vous
contrer les nombreuses fêtes news de
barbara pompili de ces derniers jours la
tenue vendredi
tout d'abord les éoliennes ne servent
pas la décarbonation puisque la france
est à 80 % décarbonés et que les
éoliennes ne peuvent pas décarbonés
supplémentaires par rapport aux
nécessités déjà culte et carbonées et en
outre les éoliennes comme elle le
produit simplement 24 7 % de leur
capacité maximale de production oblige
l'organisation et même de contrebalancer
avec un pas que j'appelle ça un accueil
promoteurs éoliens
c'est à dire des usines au charbon au
gaz et au pétrole c'est d'ailleurs la
raison pour laquelle en allemagne
l'allemagne produit dix fois plus de gaz
à effet de serre mais oui monsieur lanoë
votre pays d'exemplarité bien avec 30%
de charbon et 30% des éoliennes
produisent
fois plus de gaz à effet de serre pour
la france c'est un échec retentissant
les éoliennes ne sont pas une énergie
d'avenir et vont progressivement et
démantelé dans le cadre d'une politique
de démantèlement progressif en tout cas
que nous allons nous
frédéric lanoë beaucoup de choses à
envoyer secouer la tête aux arguments de
fabien bouglé alors on répondait des
feuilles quiniou sur les éoliennes en
france et notamment par la voix de la
ministre de l'écologie écoutez monsieur
bouclé il est fiscaliste et juristes
pour le patrimoine
monsieur stéphane bern s'occupe de
patrimoine et se permet de parler de
sujets éminemment scientifique puisqu'on
en est là en face du les gens on sort
d'une crise profonde
on a vu qu'on a pu avec résilience
fournir l'électricité parce que les
éoliennes ou continuer de produire
on voit qu'il faut changer notre mode de
notre logiciel est bien parce que
qu'est-ce qui arrive le plus grand des
tsunamis c'est celui du réchauffement
climatique et par rapport à ça qu'est ce
qu'on nous propose les vieilles
solutions le pétrole le nucléaire alors
pourtant la semaine dernière puisque
vous si vous parlez de l'actualité la
semaine dernière l'agencé internationale
de l'énergie qui fait foi dans le
domaine qui a son siège à paris a sorti
un document disant il faut
impérativement cesser tout
investissement dans les faux sites
immédiatement 80% des stocks connu
doivent rester sous terre et en deux il
faut investir massivement et à 2050 dans
30 ans il y aura deux piliers dans le
mix énergétique mondial à 35%
ça sera le solaire et à 35% ça sera
l'éolien et ça c'est des spécialistes
qui le disent et pourquoi ils le disent
parce qu'en fait cette énergie non
seulement aller les propres mais en plus
elle est devenue compétitive
n'oubliez pas que j'étais bien dans le
rythme surtout que maintenant c'est deux
sens
et 90 faut pas raconter des âneries
c'est passé grâce aux subventions que
vous touchez non vous vous trompez le
plus sûr des appels d'offres et
entretenue autour de 50 à 60 euros le
mégawattheure mais en même temps
messieurs parce qu'on veut on vous
entend pas et autour de leur marathon
photo mais là on voit les plots cv causé
des élections a dit pas scientifique est
maintenue en mai tandis que j'étais
sorti des classifications ce que je
voudrais dire c'est que les temps sont
représentés que vous même et quelques
jardins on a vu un sondage qui montre
que 82 % des français et c'est là si tu
de radioprotection du clair s'il le fait
les personnages que vous avez de china
mobile et c'est vrai que ça fait partie
d'une un des axes de ce débat c'est
assez étonnant ce qui se passe avec les
éoliennes parce que monsieur bouclé
pardon la noé à raison les français sont
plutôt apprécié les éoliennes 82% ont
une bonne image de l'énergie éolienne
sauf souvent quand ils sont à côté des
éoliennes
comment vous l'expliquez alors non pas
d'un sondage qu'elle était je ne sens
pas que mon livre qu'elle est financée
par france énergie éolienne dans le plan
pluriannuel de l'énergie à une
consultation des partis qui montre que
70% des personnes se sont opposés aux
éoliennes
lorsqu'il y a des défunts d'hommes
réalisés dans les communes à proximité
des centrales éoliennes
il ya une opposition de 80% dans la paix
et dans la presse quotidienne régionale
lorsqu'il ya des sondages réalisés par
les journaux qui a une opposition de 4%
et piétinent à paris
abc lampre c'est comme si vous devenez
mowgli sondage sur l'axé et raisonnable
répondre parce que ça va dans le sens à
excuser moi ça va dans le sens de faire
venir google voudrait vous faire écouter
le député à l'ère du vaucluse julien
aubert qui applaudissait à cette tribune
de stéphane bern écoutez bravo à
stéphane bern l'éolien c'est plus de 90
milliards d'euros pour une électricité
non stockables des acteurs locaux ignoré
des riverains excédés un résultat
carbone incertain aucune écologie ne se
construira durablement sans l'homme et
frédéric lanoë c'est vrai que son bac il
est très théorique il existe c'est vrai
mais quand on est à côté les riverains
soient ses excès d comment vous vous
l'expliquer mais je lui explique parce
que c'est du bon sens on voit bien que
c'est l'énergie nationale j'entends
beaucoup de politiques et notamment de
la droite qui s'expriment contre
l'éolien et je trouve ça complètement
incompréhensible des gens qui se veulent
conservateurs devraient avoir conscience
que la preuve le premier des capitales
c'est l'environnement il nous faut le
conserver en 2d vend des gens qui ont
été prompts industrie devrait bien voir
qu'à une révolution industrielle qui est
en train de se jouer
on peut pas la laisser aux chinois aux
américains avec joe bayer donne
maintenant et aux allemands et autres on
doit s'en saisir de même que l'industrie
française s'est saisie de l'automobile
donc la défense
à droite on ne contractent pas toujours
que conservation de l'environnement
promotion de ligue occupions 5000 abymes
avec les énergéticiens petite porte et
l'éolien longtemps outre son époux donc
attendez pas cher quand même temps s'il
vous plaît elle après l'autre merci
à qui depuis des années ça arrange pour
préserver les réserves halieutiques
vous êtes en train de détruire aux
pêcheurs aux 2500 familles de vous
écrire ils ont plus que fait monsieur
vous êtes à la nature parler aux
français qui voient les éoliennes
défiguré vous avez vous la portez vous
sur vos attentes et nos matchs déjà que
vous êtes on skype vous parler en même
temps l'un des prénoms s'il vous plaît
comme ça on sortira de ce débat en ayant
appris peu après l'autre s'il vous plaît
voilà alors d'être léger pardonnez moi
mais là parce que c'est ce qui vient
revient souvent fabien bouglé sur les
nuisances rapporté fiable est-ce qu'on a
des données vraiment fiables sur les
nuisances que prouvant que les éoliennes
sur les rivera et après on laissera la
réponse à frédéric lanoë l'un après
l'autre s'il vous plaît ya quand même
des normes et une ornithologique
particulier la ligue de protection des
oiseaux de seabird internationale qui
montre qu' il ya une atteinte aux
oiseaux et que les rôles gays sont des
oies choir rapaces ya encore eu un
rapace très très rare qui a été
déchiqueté ces derniers jours qu'on
retrouve sur les réseaux sociaux et la
ligue de protection des oiseaux a fait
un communiqué presse en disant qu'ils
avaient à minima 60000 rapaces morts ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est que seabird
internationale en espagne fait un
rapport en 2011 qui précise qu'une plume
millions d'oiseaux qui meurent par en
espagne depuis lors ils ont été financés
par iberdrola qui le principal promoteur
espagnol
il a plus de problème d'oiseaux en
espagne et on ne dit pas ça monsieur la
lp au dic c'est entre 1 et 20 oiseaux
qui éventuellement vont mourir par une
éolienne un chat errant ses 60 à 100 par
an comparé les autoroutes et le fléau
numéro un
allez c'est moi je vous laisse les
parler s'il vous plaît à frédéric lanoë
eux
monsieur bré s'il vous plaît on est sur
les nuisances effectivement sur
l'environnement la faune animale n'y a
pas que sa mémé déjà prononcés dans la
renommée des études sont faites et pour
répondre à une tribune de stéphane bern
les architectes des bâtiments de france
veille à ce qu'on se rapproche pas il ya
un périmètre d'exclusion du mont saint
michel et cetera tout est fait avec
beaucoup beaucoup de précautions et des
experts passent font des relevés et non
il est faux de dire que c'était un choix
d asseoir azot ddt centaines d'études
montrent que les oiseaux passent au
dessus ou en dessous ou sur les côtés
parce qu'ils voient et elle tourne de
plus en plus gravement
en revanche de quoi il meurt il meurt du
réchauffement climatique
marseille va devenir une fournaise
caniculaire ça c'est le haut niveau
vous n'avez toujours pas proposé un
début de solution monsieur bouclé depuis
le début de ce débat je n'ai pas proposé
de suspendre manque c'est bien ça les
solutions des gens qui le pratiquent
élections libres et le pays.le
décarbonés au monde monsieur lannoy von
sternberg d'un vote
je tiens la fin il a beaucoup manqué il
sera bref du coup les verra quand même
temps écouter c'est mon père on vous
entend pas du pouvoir de demain il ya un
documentaire qui sort de charles petit
mon dieu qui sait y est un documentaire
de documentaires et méritée qui
s'appelle du rêve à la réalité qui en
1h05 en détruit toutes les fêtes news de
monsieur lèvres et de ses collègues
lobbyistes de l'éolien frédéric jeannot
et on a compris
frédéric lanoë moi j'ai une question
j'ai une question d'un de nos vies ce
qu'on joue nous écoute vous écharpés sur
le sujet avec beaucoup de passion et
et bien comme ça mais qui croire quand
on connaît mal ce sujet et comment être
sûr qu'il n'y a pas justement des
lobbystes aulas tout simplement chacun
défend ses intérêts peut-être parfois
financiers et quelles sont les vraies
raisons objectives de ne pas vouloir ou
de vouloir de ces éoliennes elles ce
qu'on le saura un jour avec des données
fiables est clair vous avez quand même
la source du ministère frédéric lanoë
pour la réponse excusez moi chacun la
trame stratégie ces oppositions
systématiques
vous avez quand même le ministère de
l'économie et du développement durable
qui a mis un vrai faux qui est très
clair vous avez l'insolence
internationale de l'énergie cas ce qu'a
longtemps été pro pétrole puis pro
nucléaire et qui maintenant reconnaît
que la plus compétitive et la plus
propre ceo lien plus solaire il y aura
toujours une parle pour le nucléaire je
suis bouclé mais quand les réacteurs
vont devoir s'arrêter parce qu'on va pas
aller jusqu'à ce qu'ils pètent sont les
d'accord mais on peut pas les remplacer
par des repères parce que le p r c'est
trois fois plus cher que l'éolien et le
solaire
ce n'est pas une solution pour
l'économie française or maintenant on a
des usines
on a des usines à saint nazaire on a une
usine de pales à cherbourg on à en avoir
il faut les faire tourner un vrai défi
industriel et je pense que au moment où
on un pays qui a une dette abyssale
au moment où on a une économie du
chômage eh bien il faut aussi raisonner
en terme économique dont sort seulement
0 grain beaucoup et donc vous allez
acheter
justement que je pose est comment être
sûr voilà qui viennent en france
à ceci s'ajoute le monde de la pêche les
gens qui sont là pour protéger leur
métier les milliers de familles
françaises qui défendent leur bout de
gras et leur métier qui va être détruit
pas ces personnes lobby éolien
je voudrais rappeler que nous nous
défendons le de manière totalement
désintéressée le bien commun nous
défendons la france
ses paysages son patrimoine
l'un est fondé à la capitale qui est
installée au sein même du ministère de
l'écologie qui s'appelle l'ofas de
l'office franco-allemand de la
transition énergétique qui a son siège
social à berlin et gacé locher bien la
transition inachevée club dans son
ensemble que vous pour fonder lise
installé c'est bien la transition
énergétique dans son ensemble est à
faire pour lutter justement contre ces
fossoyeurs de la france de ses paysages
et de son patrimoine culturel naturel
voilà
mais vous il pas qu contre les pylônes
électriques historienne calcul contre la
tour eiffel surya pas du compte que le
péché le débat était passionné merci en
tout cas d'avoir été avec nous d'avoir
plus que jouer le jeu du face à face ce
soir fabien bouglé y avait pas besoin de
beaucoup c'est trop frédéric lanoë merci
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france et dans le reste de l'actualité à
saint-claude dans le jura les 280
salariés de la fonderie mbf seront fixés
sur leur avenir le 15 juin prochain la
résine est menacé par une liquidation
judiciaire ils se mobilisent pour
trouver des solutions et cherche le
soutien des politiques
reportage on au parquet avec le récit
d'emilie google le premier d'une reprise
par les salariés des salariés en lutte
pour sauver leur usine et leur emploi
ils ont décidé de prendre leur destin en
mains sur la table la création d'une
scop société coopérative et
participative
ce pourrait être une autre alternative
pour les 280 salariés de la fonderie mbf
dans l'attenté d'une décision du
tribunal de commerce sur l'unique offre
de rachat de leur entreprise
ça fait soixante jours que nous sommes
en lutte nous sommes toujours dans
spectateurs de ce qui va nous
arrivé on emboîte les audiences il
airport mais avoue d'un moment je pense
que il faut prendre les choses en main
et notre avenir
il faut que les salariés le dessine
eux-mêmes sur le projet d'une scop et
porter cette initiative là au plus haut
niveau de l'état puisque c'est un projet
innovant avec l'accompagnement
éventuellement de l'état et de la région
sur ce projet-là leur usine est à
l'arrêt depuis le 31 mars pour
communiquer leur désarroi ils ont déjà
réalisé plusieurs opérations coup de
poing notamment une grève de la faim
les salariés ont du mal à faire entendre
leur voix et regrette que les politiques
se désintéresse de leur sort ce jour là
seul un député a fait le déplacement
pour les soutenir l'élu communiste
fabien roussel
d'abord je suis venu ici pour leur dire
qu'ils ont raison de se mobiliser et que
s'il ne se mobilisait pas comme cela on
ne parlerait pas deux et c'est pour cela
qu'ils ont besoin d'être soutenus et
qu'on vienne ici leur dire une scop
c'est une des pistes il y à des
entreprises dans l'industrie qui
fonctionne sous forme de scop je dis
même que celle à venir demain parce que
au moins dans ces entreprises les
salariés ont leur mot à dire sur les
richesses qu'ils créent sur comment les
investir et aux services de quel projet
industriel donc oui ça peut être
l'avenir
fabien roussel leur a promis de porter
leur combat devant l'assemblée nationale
la liquidation judiciaire de la fonderie
aurait de lourdes conséquences pour
saint claude et représenterait un échec
pour la région qui se bat contre les
délocalisations la fonderie d'aluminium
est le premier employeur privé de la
ville
en attendant les salariés restent
suspendus à la décision du tribunal de
commerce de dijon le 15 juin prochain
aux etats unis moins d'une semaine après
le premier anniversaire de la mort de
john floyd le pays commémore aujourd'hui
demain un autre crime racial le massacre
de tout ça les faits remontent au 31 mai
et 1er juin 1921 des émeutes à tulsa
ville dans l'oklahoma soldée par la mort
de près de 300 afro-américains leurs
familles réclament toujours justice
aujourd'hui j'y ai marre aussi
nous sommes en 1921 à greenwood une
banlieue d'environ dix mille âmes au
nord de tulsa la deuxième plus grande
ville d'oklahoma dans le sud des états
unis
il se trouve que green wood est un
quartier noir est même l'un des plus
prospères du pays attirant de riches
entrepreneurs noirs et jouissant d'une
économie florissante
on surnomme même cet endroit le black
wall street of america enfin ça c'est
non donné aujourd'hui car à l'époque on
parlait plutôt dans la presse locale de
hole street
car oui nous sommes dans les années 20
et le racisme et la ségrégation sont
toujours 2000 à tout ça à ce moment là
la lois jim crow qui interdit aux noirs
d'accéder au bâtiment réservé aux blancs
il y a encore cours
de plus la réussite de greenwood
apparaît comme une insulte aux yeux de
nombreux habitants blancs notamment ceux
revenus de la grande guerre et qui
souffre de la concurrence noir sur le
marché du travail
ajoutez à cela la présence du klu klux
klan et vous avez là tous les
ingrédients du cocktail explosif qui va
mener aux événements qu'on a appelé le
massacre de tulsa le 30 mai 1921 dit
crosland un cireur de chaussures afro
américain de 19 ans trébuche
malencontreusement sur sarah paige 17
ans et surtout blanche
dès le lendemain il est arrêté pour vous
donner une idée de l'ambiance qui règne
à ce moment le tulle sa tribune titre ce
jour là je cite un attrapés pour
avoir attaqué une fille dans un
ascenseur de là tout s'emballe
une foule blanche réclame rowland pour
le lyncher des patrouilles noir armée
s'organise pour les en empêcher
les deux groupes se font face un premier
coup de feu est tiré la suite c'est
viola fletcher plus anciennes survivante
qui la raconte la nuit du massacre
j'ai été réveillé par ma famille
avant et mes cinq frères et soeurs
étaient l'arbre vert on a dit que nous
devions partir et c'est tout je
n'oublierai jamais la violence de la
foule blanche lorsque nous avons quitté
notre maison
je vois encore des hommes noirs se faire
tirer dessus décor noir gisant dans la
rue n'exclut ni assez je sens quand la
fumée je vois encore le feu je vois
encore des commerces noir brûlé à jean
temps quand les avions volaient au
dessus de nos têtes
j'entends les cris j'ai vécu au
quotidien avec le souvenir de ce
massacre des à l'aube du 1er juin
greenwood est envahie par une foule
blanche de plusieurs milliers de
personnes
le quartier est presque entièrement rasé
les commerces sont pillés quelques 1250
logements sont détruits parfois à l'aide
d'avions lâchant des bombes incendiaires
une demi douzaine d'églises une école le
seul hôpital de la ville et plus de 130
entreprises sont réduites en cendres le
bilan humain officiel est de 45 morts en
réalité un rapport de 2001 leur évalue
entre 100 et 300 victimes et il pourrait
être bien plus élevé encore les
habitants de greenwood eux n'ont jamais
obtenu réparation
glenn gould aurait dû être ma chance de
réussir dans ce pays dans quelques
heures tout ceci a disparu
je suis ici pour demander justice et je
demande à mon pays de reconnaître ce qui
s'est passé à tout ça en 1921 à cause du
massacre
ma famille a été chassé de notre maison
à 11 oui mais nous n'avions plus rien
oui nous sommes devenus des réfugiés
dans notre propre pays
quand cette histoire longtemps oubliés
est réapparu au début des années 2000 et
le 100e anniversaire du massacre de
tulsa revêt une symbolique toute
particulière aux états unis alors qu'un
autre anniversaire celui de la mort de
jack floyd il y a un an vient d'être
commémoré et c'est la fin de cette
émission merci de l'avoir suivi prochain
point complet sur l'actualité
en quelques minutes avec emilie google
quant à moi j'aurai le plaisir de vous
retrouver demain soir à 20 heures
[Musique]
pour beaucoup le foot a été synonyme
d'évasion durant cette période de la
pandémie
quel est le rôle justement du football
dans notre société en temps de crise je
pense ça a été bien de continuer le
football pour s'évader un peu aussi haut
niveau au niveau mental
on est tous conscients que le football
ligny tout ce qui est au niveau social
surtout au niveau culture et quel regard
portez-vous sur toutes ces années à
mouna trop à la joie